dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale quel rôle doit selon vont jouer
à levin et quel rôle joue-t-elle dans
les faits les villes tout comme les
états ils étaient pas préparés
mais les villes elles se sont connectés
tout de suite entre elles pour voir
comment elles pouvaient coopérer
il ya eu l'envoi des beaucoup de des
masques de matériels médicaux d'une
commune à l'autre selon vous à quoi
pourront ressembler les îles comment est
ce qu elle pour transformer après la
pandémie la crise maintenant à fait bien
comprendre qu'on peut pas s'oublier des
banlieues on peut pas oublier les
quartiers pauvres parce que
véritablement elles font partie de la
vie donc les grandes villes quand il se
connecte
elle ne part pas seulement d'elle-même
elle parle aussi de comment créer cette
cercle vertueux avec les villes des
alentours
[Musique]
première sortie du chef de l'état hors
épidémie aujourd'hui dans l'aisne
emmanuel macron a rendu hommage à
charles de gaulle le lancement d'une
série d'hommages au chef de la france
libre après de vifs échanges avec le
personnel hospitalier
l'exécutif qui lance aussi son nouveau
plan pour l'hôpital de meilleures
rémunérations une réorganisation des
soins c'est ce que promet aujourd'hui le
ministre de la santé dans la presse
alors que 25 nouveaux foyers de
contamination ont été recensés en france
depuis le début de la semaine la relance
du tourisme en europe avec une
réouverture des frontières en ordre
dispersé
aucune concertation entre les pays
membres alors que la récession
économique se confirme l'espagne et
l'italie ont décidé de rouvrir leur pays
aux touristes avant tout le monde
res qui a provoqué l'agacement du
ministre de l'intérieur français
l'europe qui enregistre à elle seule
plus de la moitié de la mortalité dans
le monde avec plus de 180 mille dessins
[Musique]
les pilotes de la plus longue crise
politique de l'histoire moderne d'israël
avec la prestation de serment
aujourd'hui du nouveau gouvernement
d'union nationale le parlement a
approuvé ce nouvel exécutif bicéphale
benyamin nétanyahou pour la droite son
ancien rival politique benny gantz pour
le centre est pour la première fois à la
knesset une femme ultra orthodoxes et
une ministre d'origine éthiopienne
il est temps d'annexer dépend de la
cisjordanie avec l'arrêt benyamin
nétanyahou dans son discours
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce dimanche le lancement
des commémorations au général de gaulle
aujourd'hui c'est une première pour un
président sous la vème république
emmanuel macron s'est rendu à montcornet
dans l'ain dans l'aisne théâtre d'une
bataille méconnu de charles roux charles
de gaulle s'est illustré alors qu'il
était colonel admirateurs revendiqué de
son illustre prédécesseur
le chef de l'état a voulu célébrer
l'esprit français
et c'est le début d'une longue série
d'hommages cette année thomas bonnin
pour son premier déplacement non liés à
l'épidémie de kovy de 19 depuis plus de
deux mois le président de la république
a choisi le département de l'aisne une
visite prévue de longue date puisqu'elle
marque la première étape d'une année
d'hommages rendus au général de gaulle
emmanuel macron a prononcé un discours
pour commémorer la bataille de france et
plus particulièrement les combats de
montcornet qui se sont déroulés en mai
1940 un discours à la teneur très
historique mais dont certains passages
peuvent être lus à la lumière des
récents événements de gaulle nous dit
que la france est forte quand elle c'est
son destin quand elle se tient unis
qu'elles cherchent la voie de la
cohésion au nom d'une certaine idée de
la france qui nous rassemblent par delà
les discordes alors devenue accessoire
et les désaccords souvent trop festive
une ode à l'unité nationale un appel au
dépassement des clivages qui s'inscrit
dans la lignée de la volonté du
président de la république
l'hypothèse d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale apparaît d'ailleurs dans la
presse depuis maintenant plusieurs
semaines
la tentation est grande donc de se
mettre dans les pas du général de gaulle
personnalité qui fait aujourd'hui
quasiment l'unanimité
cependant cet héritage se heurte aux
nombreuses réserves des oppositions
politiques de droite comme de gauche
pour certains emmanuel macron mêmes
l'antithèse du général de gaulle
macron au nord de gaulle macron qui en
même temps voulait réhabiliter pétain
qui détruit l'héritage social du conseil
national de la résistance qui brade la
souveraineté et l'indépendance de la
france
il est le contraire de de gaulle le
destructeur de son oeuvre
mascarade emmanuel macron et la
politique
il mène son psy contraire à l'esprit et
à la lettre du gaullisme que l'hommage à
charles de gaulle depuis montcornet
résonne hélas comme une énième insulte à
la nation
les arguments déjà exprimée il ya près
de deux ans lorsque l'évolution du logo
de l'elysée avait été remarqué une croix
de lorraine il faisant son apparition il
y avait eu aussi les mémoires de charles
de gaulle ouvrage savamment disposés sur
le bureau l'elysée pour la photo
officielle du président la tentative de
captation du gaullisme par emmanuel
macron véritable artifices de cobb
comment peut-on se prétendre gaulliste
lorsqu'on veut une europe fédérale qu'on
dit l'existence d'une culture française
et qu'on accepte de vendre deux
aéroports à des puissances étrangères
difficile à assumer sur le fond la
comparaison avec de bol il est aussi sur
la forme celui qui a incarné la france
libre et de loin le président le plus
populaire d'une vème république
rédigé sur mesure pour lui emmanuel
macron à l'instar de certains de ses
prédécesseurs tente donc un parallèle
père yves n'importe quel responsable
politique qui voudrait faire croire aux
français qu'il va marcher dans les pas
de de gaulle donnerait l'impression d'un
enfant qui a chaussé les bottes de son
papa vous voyez il ya une impression un
peu ridicule à la limite ce qu'il faut
faire c'est aller piocher aller lille
rue général de gaulle sans dire et s'en
inspirer pour que transparaissent à
travers notre action l'esprit de ce que
le général de gaulle a voulu insuffler
en matière de grandeur de la france en
matière de puissance externe emmanuel
macron fait la laisse le quotidien le
monde nous apprend par exemple que le
président de la république se serait
replongé dans l'histoire du général pour
y puiser une inspiration sûr je cite
comment un homme d'étape se servir
d'événements dramatiques pour redresser
la nation
mais face à tant de vent contraire il
n'est pas certain que même les mémoires
du général de gaulle suffisent à
emmanuel macron toujours contesté par
une grande partie des français
et en ce qui concerne la crise sanitaire
sachez que 25 foyers de contamination
ont été recensés en france depuis le
début de la semaine 34 employés d'un
abattoir dans le loiret ont été testés
positifs
aucun cas grave idem dans les côtes
d'armor avec quatre personnes infectées
trois en ile-de-france dans un foyer de
jeunes travailleurs
le ministre de la santé a rappelé dans
le jdd aujourd'hui que le virus circule
est toujours même dans les zones vertes
1 mayotte est le seul endroit où
l'épidémie est encore en progression
le ministre de la santé qui a dévoilé
aujourd'hui son plan pour l'hôpital dans
le journal du dimanche il indique
vouloir organiser je cite un ségur de la
santé dès le 25 mai il promet une
amélioration des rémunérations pour les
salariés en particulier pour les femmes
un programme d'investissement une
réorganisation des soins mais aussi une
révision du temps de travail des
annonces faites par voie de presse
accueillis avec circonspection regarder
[Musique]
une crise sanitaire qui va peut-être
sonné le glas de la majorité absolue des
macros nist à l'assemblée dès demain 22
députés veulent créer un nouveau groupe
intitulé écologie démocratie solidarité
et ce serait le neuvième à siéger dans
l'hémicycle et parmi les frondeurs vous
le voyez aurélien tâche et figure de la
gauche de la république en marche il a
annoncé aujourd'hui qu'il quittait le
parti des manuels macron dans le jdd
sans préciser s'il allait rejoindre ce
nouveau groupe parlementaire
voyez l'analyse de nicolas vidal
directeur de publication de tout média
concrètement aujourd'hui on se rend
compte que au delà de cet effritement de
la reine d'ailleurs il est il est engagé
depuis certains mois il ya eu beaucoup
de départs de quoi tu là dessus ce que
ça montre nécessairement c'est cette
fracture majeure entre la majorité des
français et le pouvoir politique et la
classe politique
et ça c'est extrêmement importante parce
que j'ai l'impression que même pas j'ai
l'impression je suis j'en suis sûr que
manuel macro va avoir de plus en plus de
mal à gouverner
à la sortie sacré du courant navires us
on a vu d'ailleurs alléger les jeunes
qui ont tenté de reprendre des rues
hier pardon au samedi donc tout ça va
être très compliqué et en plus bon
emmanuel macron avec sa loi d'urgence
sanitaire tout cela n'est pas fait pour
apaiser le pays et on notera aussi son
rapport à la souveraineté française
qu'il essaye de dire comme l'espèce de
mantra de plus en plus régulièrement et
notamment son hommage au général de
gaulle aujourd'hui on sait que manuelle
gautrand c'est pas le gardien d'étape de
la vision gaulliste des français qu'ils
ont pu pour la première fois depuis huit
semaines profiter d'un week end un peu
plus libre sur les plages ou dans les
parcs mais aussi sur certains sites
touristiques qui ont pu rouvrir
c'est le cas notamment à lourdes où
chaque année la ville accueille 6
millions de visiteurs il y en avait un
peu moins cette fois au lieu de
pèlerinage pour les chrétiens voyez ce
reportage d'hervé grand champ c'est face
à des bancs vides que le recteur du
sanctuaire de lourdes a célébré sa messe
samedi
pas de célébration de culte ni d'accès
aux piscines pour les fidèles
fermé depuis deux mois le sanctuaire
vient enfin de rouvrir ses portes à
cause de la fermeture du lieu depuis le
17 mars
plusieurs millions d'euros de pertes
sont prévus d'ici la fin de l'année
je vois l'avenir avec inquiétude parce
qu'effectivement la situation économique
de lourdes et complexes à l'image de ce
qu'est la situation du bassin lourdais
en l'absence de pèlerins pendant deux
mois l'absence de pèlerinage jusqu'à la
fin juillet sans doute l'a entraîné il
serait certainement une perte de l'ordre
de 8 millions d'euros pour l'ensemble du
sanctuaire mais je vois aussi l'avenir
avec confiance parce que je sais que la
générosité des pèlerins n'a jamais fait
défaut aux sanctuaires dans le passé
toujours lorsqu'il ya une difficulté
les pèlerins se sont manifestés pour
faire en sorte que ce sanctuaire puisse
venir puissent vivre et aujourd'hui je
le suis confiant je suis joyeux d'ouvrir
et je lance cet appel avec sincérité
avec humilité mais déjà avec
reconnaissance et des lourdes à se
remettre et des lourdes à préparer
l'avenir pour assurer la sécurité
sanitaire des pèlerins et des malades
des mesures strictes ont été prises
le but est d'éviter toute propagation du
virus dans ce lieu habitué à accueillir
chaque année des centaines de milliers
de pèlerins
et pour cela le port du masque est
obligatoire et le marquage au sol doit
être respectée après confinement on peut
sortir de chez nous attend qu'il arrête
et on est à 94 km d'ici
moi je suis venu une fois
adolescente a en tout cas
[ __ ] hier et c'est un lieu dont trois
enfants
c'est beau de venir
et voilà c'est pour ton bien dire merci
à la
hier jeumont
on ya trouvé
mon appel pour les
depuis
[Applaudissements]
quand on voit tout évident alors que
c'est un endroit où il ya il ya l'amitié
il ya
il ya vraiment des choses qu'on ne voit
pas ailleurs c'est à dire qu'on soit
jeune âgé ou pauvres
ou riches on est tous à la même enseigne
on se parle c'est un emploi on se parle
bien et puis couper tout ça énorme
les visiteurs ne rend que 10 par dix
dans le sanctuaire où des bénévoles
veillent au respect des distances de
sécurité des gestes barrières
si l'on sentait de nouveau ouverte de
14h à 18h la reprise des célébrations
publiques n'a pas encore été décidée par
les autorités
en espagne la situation s'améliore
progressivement comme un peu partout en
europe d'ailleurs pour la première fois
le nombre de morts est passé sous la
barre symbolique des 100 décès avec 87
morts exactement ces dernières 24 heures
l'espagne qui reste l'un des pays les
plus touchés par la pandémie avec 27
mille six cent cinquante morts je vous
rappelle que la france elle a dépassé le
seuil des 28 mille décès avec près de
500 décès ces dernières 24 heures nous
avons un très faible nombre de morts en
dessous 287 décédé pour la première fois
depuis longtemps nous passons sous la
barre des 100 décédé la baisse
progressivement et nous sommes pour la
première fois depuis longtemps en
dessous des 100 morts ce qui est une
bonne nouvelle
bien qu'il soit toujours dur de parler
des décès liés à cette maladie
la relance du tourisme en europe avec
une réouverture des frontières en ordre
dispersé puisque il n'y a aucune
concertation entre les pays membres
alors que la récession économique se
confirme l'espagne et l'italie ont
décidé de rouvrir leur pays aux
touristes avant tout le monde ce qui a
provoqué l'agacement du ministre de
l'intérieur français hier l'europe qui
enregistre à elle seule plus de la
moitié de la mortalité dans le monde
avec plus de 180 mille décès grégoire
douce et les vingt-sept ne parviennent
pas à accorder leurs violons
une coordination difficile à l'heure où
les autorités italiennes ont pris tout
le monde à contre-pied avec une annonce
ce samedi leurs frontières seront
ouvertes à partir du 3 juin
juninho à la pause sybille est à partir
du 3 juin prochain il sera possible de
voyager à l'intérieur des pays de l'ue
opn sans obligation de quarantaine pour
ceux qui arrivent en italie
cela favorisera la création des
conditions d'une reprise du tourisme est
la quarantaine lever une mesure forte
dans un pays où le tourisme est un
secteur clé de l'économie autres pays
européens très touchée elle l'espagne
adopte une stratégie différente les
étrangers arrivant dans la péninsule
ibérique seront contraints à partir du
22 mai à une mise à l'isolément de 14
jours une décision que regrette la
france qui a imposé aux espagnols la
même mesure par réciprocité
le ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner appel à plus de coordination à
l'échelle du continent
je pense que il est essentiel que nous
puissions avoir des décisions
coordonnées au niveau européen surtout
sur les rachats miel et ce n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui et la décision
unilatérale de l'espagne cette semaine
de l'italie annoncé ce matin
comporte pas ce que nous devons faire
travailler ensemble en solidarité donc
j'aurai l'occasion d'échanger avec nos
homologues dans le week-end pour que
nous puissions adapter nos règles si
certains pays consentent que la
protection de l'espace européen
notamment des avis de pays où le virus
est encore plus actifs même pour au sein
de l'europe les élus de territoire sur
lequel le virus soit en parfait
équilibre
ils seront amenés à proposer au
président de prendre des décisions qui
protégeront les pensées symboliquement
réuni à schengen au luxembourg les chefs
des diplomaties allemandes et
luxembourgeoises espèrent de leur côté
une réouverture progressive des
frontières européennes
à condition que les données sanitaires
le permettent europa league
l'europe est fondée sur le fait qu'elle
est sans frontières et je crois que les
citoyens ne comprendrait plus très
longtemps une europe ayant des
frontières
c'est pourquoi nous avons une grande
responsabilité dans la lutte contre la
pandémie et si nous continuons à réussir
en éliminant progressivement les
contrôles aux frontières que nous avons
mises en place l'europe sera à nouveau
une europe sans frontières et c'est ce
que les citoyens attendent
la commission européenne souhaite une
réouverture concertée si des décisions
plus précises sont attendus d'ici à la
mi juin elle les états de l'ue eux
avancent pour le moment en ordre
dispersé
les pilotes de la plus longue crise
politique de l'histoire moderne d'israël
avec la prestation de serment
aujourd'hui du nouveau gouvernement
d'union nationale le parlement qui a
approuvé aujourd'hui un nouvel exécutif
bicéphale avec benyamin nétanyahou pour
la droite et son ancien rival politique
benny gantz pour le centre pour la
première fois à la knesset il y à une
femme ultra orthodoxes ainsi qu'une
ministre d'origine éthiopienne et ils
étendaient l'excès dépend de la
cisjordanie a déclaré benyamin
nétanyahou dans son discours aurait
coûté le métro aux hawks et territoires
en cisjordanie sont là où le peuple juif
est né s'est développée il est temps
d'appliquer la loi israélienne et
d'écrire un nouveau chapitre glorieux
dans l'histoire du sionisme
le gouvernement israélien qui met ainsi
un terme à cinq cents jours d'impasse
politique avec trois élections
successives sans vainqueur désigné
retour en images sur cette crise
politique sans précédent dans l'histoire
du pays
[Musique]
e
on
monde
[Musique]
nous
non
[Musique]
vous
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
jacques benillouche journalistes
israéliens
bonsoir jacques benillouche merci
beaucoup d'être avec vous sur rt france
est ce que la crise est terminée on
israel le fait qu'il y ait enfin un
gouvernement
c'est une bonne nouvelle la crise est
terminée mais les problèmes vous
commencez par ce que il y a beaucoup de
différences dans les approches
politiques des deux gouverneurs des deux
gouvernements
alors il y a d'abord le problème le plus
important qui nous concerne aujourd'hui
c'est le problème de la lectio vous avez
trois plans d'alexion différentes selon
la personne nous avons le plan d'alexion
de train le plan d'injection de gans et
le plan d'alexion de neda liens que ce
sont trois plans différents le plus
favorable je dirais à la droite
nationaliste
en israël c'est le plan train on sent
qu'il a voulu donner satisfaction à
toute la frange je dirais une approche
que nationaliste du pays et aussi les
évangélistes chrétiens qui sont ces ses
électeurs alors le plan trump qu'est-ce
qu'elle différentiel qui ne plantera
qu'il veut annexer 130 colonies 130
implantations à travers l'ensemble du
pays l'ensemble assis verbalement et il
veut annexer une langue une langue à
langue de terre entre le lac de
tibériade et la mer morte
ça c'est le plan qui est prévu par
grands patrons en revanche le plan gans
et beaucoup plus timide
d'ailleurs il est un peu flou pendant
les élections il n'a pas voulu tellement
se prononcer il prévoit lui entre nîmes
et de maths de renforcer la sécurité
nationale et d'oeuvrer à la paix et
oeuvrer à la paix c'est tellement
général qu' on ne sait pas exactement ce
qui le fait
il ne prononce pas le mot d'alexion il
précise il prévoit le rattachement
d'implantation proche de jérusalem comme
maalé adoumim
touch qui est à 10 km pratiquement de
jérusalem est comme le ce qu'on
l'appelle gauche et young et le sud de
jérusalem est qui sont des implantations
qui touche aussi jérusalem alors lui il
est prêt à je dirais inclure ces
implantations mais ne parle pas du tout
d'alexion et c'est là où elle va être le
problème c'est qu'il va falloir trancher
nous sommes assure que natalia ou
veuille vraiment passé le sauter le pas
il sait qu'il a des problèmes il sait
qu'il a des problèmes d'abord dans son
parti c'est pas le moment de réveiller
un petit peu sur ces problèmes et il est
à l'heure actuelle soumis à la pression
de trump trump veut que tout ceci se
décide avant l'élection présidentielle
parce qu'il a besoin des voix juives aux
états unis il a besoin des voix comme je
disais évangélistes or il est en
difficulté d'abord à cause de la crise
du corona qui l'a qui la complète qui a
tué l'économie américaine et surtout
parce que joe biden lutte dépasse
maintenant sur le plan ii des sondages
donc aujourd'hui c'est 30 qui pousse
d'ateliers ou à sauter le pas or il faut
savoir que l'armée et c'est elle qui
peut organiser ces annexions entre
guillemets est bien l'armé est
totalement contre cette annexion
il ya eu récemment 200 vaches généraux
qui ont publié un document disant qu'ils
sont contre l'annexion
ils ne sont pas prêts à accepter
l'annexion et ils sont pas prêts non
plus à accepter une décla une décision
unilatérale comme elle avait eu lieu à
gaza donc que d'un tania où c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il a un genou à terre
il a accepté il a accepté contre sa
volonté de collaborer avec gand il a une
opposition interne au sein de son parti
puisqu'il a d'ailleurs été forcé
d'éliminer tous les dirigeants
historiques du likoud
donc on sent qu'il n'est pas prêt
aujourd'hui à créer un incident a créé
un problème avec cette annexion
pardon pardonnez moi ici les affaires de
corruption pour benyamin nétanyahou est
ce que la crise est passée par là et a
effacé aussi ses problèmes en sortir
renforcé de cette crise sanitaire
il ya la crise sanitaire vous voulez
parler du corona ça c'est sûr il a été
il avait bien gagné l'opération il a
bien mené l'opération et nous avons été
nous sommes parmi les pays qui avons le
moins de mort de 148 exactement ce qui
est négligeable par rapport à notre pays
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que le
gouverneur natanyahou passe en jugement
bientôt devant ces tribunaux
c'est dans quelques jours et donc il
n'est pas né pas il a d'autres chats à
fouetter que ces annexions et il n'est
pas soumis il
il est soumis comme tout citoyen au juge
et il n'y a pas d'immunité parlementaire
donc il a trop de problème à l'heure
actuelle pour créer un incident vous
savez 60% de la population n'est pas
d'accord
l'annexion parce que l'annexion ça veut
dire avoir des populations arabes qui
s'intègre dans un autre pays qui
s'intègre à israël lui enlevant
totalement son identité juive
donc c'est pour ça que je dirais que
l'état néo à genoux at elle il ya eu
trois élections qui l'ont mis en
difficulté et c'est pour ça qu'au sein
de son parti
les saints sont partis c'est un petit
peu la curée ils veulent commencer
éventuellement à l'éliminer de la
direction du parti et c'est pour ça
qu'il a été contraint de ne pas prendre
certains opposants dans son gouvernement
donc c'est pour ça que je pense que le
problème de l'annexion n'est pas un
problème fondamental nous abordons une
crise comme tous les pays une crise
économique importante
le pays israël et est un pays qui
n'avait pas chômage
eh bien nous avons un très grand saut
maja millions de chômeurs pour une
population de 8 millions c'est énorme
nous avons
des entreprises qui déposent le bilan tu
elles sont pas aidées par l'état à
l'état ne fait rien pour les pme quand
vous circulez d'en goûter sans
commerciaux je les fais ce matin il ya
des sans arrêt les magasins qui ont
fermé des boutiques de fringues des
restaurations qui des récents qui faire
donc je pense que c'est pour ça que je
veux je voudrais dire que question de
deux d'injection passe par dessus la
tête excusé mollichelli longtemps et
pourtant ça a été une des déclarations
de benyamin nétanyahou assez forte
aujourd'hui en absolument il a voulu
montrer que ils avaient besoin
il faut savoir qu'il avait besoin du
vote ne savait qu'ils allaient un doute
sur le vote de certains le certains de
ceux de membres du likoud qui était prêt
à ne pas voter la confiance
or effectivement on à 72 une majorité de
60 de ce père débuté mais il suffit que
onze députés ne votent pas ou se portent
pas ou quittent la salle
il faut que tout d'un coup on n'est pas
de nous allons donc il n'était pas
question aujourd'hui de créer l'incident
avec son parti
mais à la longue on est sûr aujourd'hui
que le 1er juillet n'est pas une date
définitive on a dit que la partie du 1er
juillet il allait faire l'annexion
à mon avis ce n'est pas une date qui est
fermé ce n'est pas une date qui est
unique et définitive
ça va traîner vous savez cette cette
histoire de cette histoire l'annexion on
l'a connu en soixante sept avec le
fameux plan allon un général et les
gagner la guerre de 67 qui avait proposé
ce plan à l'homme qui est pratiquement
le plan tron légèrement modifié donc si
on 67
c'est quelque chose qui traîne c'est
quelque chose qui traîne depuis 67 sans
aucune des décisions c'est pas
aujourd'hui qu'on va se lancer dans des
décisions alors que nous avons des
problèmes plus importants beaucoup plus
important sur le plan sécuritaire vous
savez les l'aviron voilà merci beaucoup
jacques benillouche pour votre analyse
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
sur rt france c'est la fin de ce journal
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve dans trente mille
restez avec nous
[Musique]
on va parler évidemment de l'impact
économique de cette pandémie est ce que
tous les pays africains vont être un
impact elle continue en voit vraiment
une de ses pires années de ses tantes
d'air